The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
AMY BANZAERT:
There were a couple
of questions on estimations.
So one person asked for
answers to estimations.
I try to give you orders of
magnitude and give you a sense,
but if I missed some, if you
want to email me and be like,
hey, I never really got
this one, let me know,
and I can review them.
And then also,
the other thing is
I'm never going to give you a
6.7 answer because I'm really
asking you an estimation
that has that kind of answer.
Like, some of them
do, but usually it's
not even that important
that you get to 6.7.
It's important that you get to
an order of magnitude of 10.
And as long as you're
there, I'm happy,
and so that's why
I'm not getting
to the exact
answer, which I know
is uncomfortable and not what
you're used to educationally,
but it's what the
estimation is there for.
Another person mentioned
that some people
seem like they were
taking a really long time
and getting lost
in the estimations.
So I try to give you
the right amount of time
for the estimation so
that it's reasonable,
but it is something to practice
getting more facile with,
I guess.
All right, so wind energy.
So does anyone know why
we have wind on the Earth?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Because we have heat.
AMY BANZAERT: Yes, from?
AUDIENCE: The Sun.
AMY BANZAERT: Yes so
it's kind of funny
because wind energy is basically
a funky solar energy, which
I find pleasing.
I don't know why, but I do.
There's also some Coriolis
effect stuff going around
on with the Earth rotating,
but the indirect solar energy
component is more
easy to think about
and I think is the bigger
component, though I'm not
sure of that.
So basically, you have
uneven heating of the Earth,
hot air rises, causes a pressure
drop, cold air rushes in,
and that movement is what
we're getting in wind.
So that's what's going on there.
And then a lot of
confusion sometimes
happens-- like, a lot of people
see these turbines, or not
turbines, but mills on farms.
And it's confusing.
Like, what's this versus this?
Is this just a junky
version of this?
And so the difference
is, if it's a mill,
it's extracting mechanical
power, versus a turbine
is extracting electrical power.
So these mills are very
high-torque devices
that move relatively slowly
in terms of their rotation
and are used to do things like
pump water or grind grain.
They've been around forever.
They're still really
common in the US
and in many places
for pumping water.
So if you drive
across the country,
you'll see these everywhere.
And they're still
in use, and they're
really nice and a whole
lot cheaper to build a mill
than to build a
turbine because you're
going from mechanical
work to mechanical work.
So that's very direct
and much, much cheaper
than doing the extra steps
to get from mechanical work
to electric power generation.
So a wind turbine, in
contrast, is electrical power.
They have been around a long
time too, but not basically
for most of humanity long time.
And again, they're going
to be moving very quickly
at much lower torque.
The solidity thing
to think about
is that when you
want high torque,
you want to be getting
as much of the air
hitting your blades as possible.
So that's why there's often
many, many blades or really
thick blades on a windmill,
whereas a wind turbine,
you want low
solidity, so you want
a low proportion of your blade
to be in that swept area.
So that's why a turbine is--
it looks very different.
So wind turbines, I'm
going to focus on,
but I will go back to windmills
a little bit at the end.
You have two types, right?
The horizontal and
the vertical axis.
The horizontal
axis is what you're
used to seeing around here
and what's in the news a lot
because they can go to
much higher heights,
and wind is much better the
higher you go, basically.
And so the horizontal
wind axis turbines
are the more common thing,
at least in my knowledge
before I started doing
any research into them.
So there's the rotor and
the motor are at the top.
It has to point into the wind.
The higher you go,
the better, but you
can imagine the higher you
go adds cost and difficulty.
You often try to
change your blade pitch
to maximize the efficiency
because, depending
on how fast the wind is, you
want a different blade pitch.
And they're now
really insanely huge.
[LAUGHS] So this is an insanely
huge 7-megawatt turbine,
which I think you
can see-- like,
is there a truck down
there or anything?
It's hard to get scale
when it gets this big,
but it's ridiculous.
And some of the challenges,
you can imagine,
in building this thing is
just getting all the materials
to the site because
you're probably
not going to build
your manufacturing
plant of how you build your--
I'm still a little off--
that long blade, thank you.
[LAUGHS]
You're not going to build your
blade right on the site where
you're going to want to
install your turbine, probably,
so then you have to
get your blade there.
So then you're actually limited
by the size of a train railroad
car or a large
truck or whatever.
So there's all these
crazy limits when you're
getting up to be this enormous.
So it's kind of remarkable
and challenging,
and this is of a scale that
we're not going to be touching,
of course, but it's nice
to see the extreme of what
is out there.
So this is a 7-megawatt
turbine that's actually
running now, I believe,
and they're currently
building a 10-megawatt that'll
be in production in a year
or running in a year
or two, so which
is a pretty big jump, 7 to 10.
So, yeah, it's definitely
an area that's taking off.
So how?
This is just the classic
Bernoulli drawing
to remind you how they're
spinning in the wind
and that the motion is
really dominated by the lift,
not drag.
One thing to think about is the
need to control the spin rate.
So you can imagine on days
where there's not much wind,
you might want to change
the pitch of the blade
to make sure you're maximizing
the wind you're capturing.
But on hurricane days,
you have to make sure
that your wind turbine doesn't
completely just spin out
of control.
And so this is a really nice,
relatively simple way to do it.
So you can do it
mechanically or electrically,
or you can do it manually.
So with old windmills
from 100 or 200 years ago,
there was some
poor guy whose job
it was to turn the windmill
into the wind or not,
depending on how fast.
It was so thankfully,
there's been
ways to optimize that either
mechanically or electrically.
So this is a method where
basically the weight
of the tail and the
turbine allows the tail
to stay connected to the
turbine so that the tail--
I'm getting lots of confused
faces, so I'll go slowly.
So the turbine
generally has a tail
that's exactly perpendicular.
So this plane and
the plane of the tail
are perpendicular so
that the tail makes
sure it's always pointing
into the wind, which
is what you want, except
when you're going too fast.
Now you need the tail and
the front of the turbine
to not be perpendicular
but to start to--
hypothetically, if
you're in gales,
you need it to be completely
rotated so that the wind is
just passing by the turbine.
Or if you're in a
moderate wind, where
it's too fast for the
turbine but still usable,
you want it to be
off a little bit.
And so the way this works is
that when the wind speed gets
high enough, you get some
lift in either the tail
or the turbine.
I forget how it
operates exactly.
And so that allows this
tail stop to be disengaged.
So then the turbine
rotates a little bit, which
you can see from this top view.
These are the front views,
and this is the top view.
So then the turbine
rotates a little bit,
and then the weight
balances out.
And so then the
top engages again,
and then it maintains
this angle of orientation.
And then if the wind
speed gets even higher,
again, the weights will get out
of balance, things will lift,
the stop will disengage.
So it's a really cool system
to keep your device safe,
and there's a lot
of them out there.
And so I just wanted to show
an example of what happens
when you don't remember--
where's my mouse-- to include
that or don't do it right.
So watch carefully.
So that was an expensive,
day and they're
really lucky that no
one was under there.
So I'll put it back so
you can watch it again.
Can you see?
Were you saying
couldn't see, Jess?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AMY BANZAERT: Did you
make it work, or--
AUDIENCE: The blade
just fell off.
AMY BANZAERT: What?
AUDIENCE: Did the
blade just fall off?
Like, did it just--
AMY BANZAERT: So
it rotated so fast
that I believe one of
the blades broke off.
And then once one breaks,
it's totally out of balance,
and the whole thing
just falls apart.
And it's moving
at such fast speed
that really crazy
dynamics are going on.
So, yeah, so
there's really solid
reasons to design these
right, especially when
you're talking big scale.
But even small scale, you
can imagine in a hurricane,
it's not going to be a
safe thing to be near,
and the small ones
are often near people.
OK, so the typical components
of a wind turbine--
you have your rotor.
You have your blades.
You have a brake because you
want the turbine to be turning
at a certain speed, ideally.
And so you may need to
brake, provide braking,
before you're providing
rotation out of the wind.
That's another smaller
step you can take.
You have a gearbox to get
the speed to the right speed
to power your generator.
Typically, on a
fancier wind turbine,
there's an anemometer that
provides the electrical control
with these yaw drives and
motors to rotate the turbine
into the wind or out
of the wind to maximize
the speed of your turbine
and then your tower.
And then so all
the electricity is
being generated in
this part of the body,
and then the power is
just going down the tower.
And you can imagine
the challenge
of when you need to do
maintenance on this,
and you're talking
about something really
high up that you
have to deal with it.
So the smaller turbines
that we'll be looking at,
they're all on guide
wires and on a pivot
so that you can
rotate them down so
you don't have to climb up to
do maintenance because that
requires a much sturdier
tower and is a much more
dangerous job.
Some installation considerations
that one would think
would be obvious
but aren't always--
so this is a wind turbine
that's been installed basically
on a rooftop by some trees.
So it's got two
types of objects that
are blocking the wind entirely.
So this was a
many-thousand-dollar
installation that's probably
providing zero electricity
because the wind may be
sufficient 30 meters up,
but right there is never
going to be sufficient.
So the good--
30 meters, 30 feet.
A good rule of thumb is
you want your turbine
to be 30 feet above any
obstruction within 300 feet.
And so obstructions include
houses and plants and anything
else that might be in the way.
So next up is vertical-axis
wind turbines,
and you can see there's
a huge range of them.
And you probably haven't seen
most of these in production
because, again, they don't have
the same level of efficiencies
and benefits that
horizontal-axis wind
turbines have.
But they're a whole lot
cheaper and easier to build.
So for small-scale solutions,
they can be really ideal.
There's a bunch of different
names of these different types.
So, for example, this is
called a Darrieus wind turbine.
This is a Savonius
wind turbine, which
you'll be building on Friday.
And this is a cool
combo, Savonius-Darrieus.
The Savonius will start
up automatically in wind,
and the won't but
the Darrieus gets
a little bit better efficiency.
So that combining
sort of gets you
the best of both worlds with
some drawbacks, of course, too.
And so these power
traffic lights in Taiwan.
So there are places where these
are installed effectively.
And they're kind of cool
because, as you can see here,
you can almost build
them out of anything,
and you will build them
out of anything on Friday.
Hey, Amit, do we have
enough plastic bottles,
speaking of which, for Friday?
AMIT GANDHI: [INAUDIBLE]
AMY BANZAERT: So
added to your homework
is, on Friday, you need to
bring in a plastic bottle,
like a Gatorade bottle, a
2-liter bottle, whatever.
It doesn't have to be 2 liters.
It can be 1 liter or
a 20-ounce bottle,
but we need plastic bottles.
So if everyone brings one,
we'll be in good shape.
Is that doable?
If you check the recycling
bins walking to class,
you'll find one.
[LAUGHS] Cool.
So some of the advantages,
they're closer to the ground,
so you don't have any
line losses compared
to the horizontal-axis
wind turbine.
You don't need any
yaw or pitch control
because they're
just in the wind.
They're intended to be in
the wind, and that works.
And they work generally
for lower wind speeds,
which means lower heights.
They are often much less noisy
than horizontal-axis wind
turbines, and they can
often start at lower speeds.
But some of the disadvantages,
they're hard to scale up.
So you're never going to get a
7-megawatt vertical-axis wind
turbine.
That's just not viable.
They're generally
less efficient,
and they're more
prone to fatigue,
so they do wear out more
easily because they're
capturing so much more
of the wind, typically.
But for our purposes,
they're definitely
a possibility to look at.
For anything, just a
reminder of the equations
we're thinking about--
so the force that
you're receiving
is equivalent to 1/2
times rho Av squared.
So v is obviously the
velocity of the wind,
the cross-sectional area swept,
and the density of the wind.
The maximum possible
power extraction
is dominated by
the velocity cubed.
So, obviously, velocity is
going to be-- your wind velocity
is really going to
be what you worry
about when you're designing.
So area is important, obviously,
but the velocity's cubed,
so the wind speed is huge.
So whenever you're
thinking, is this a place
where the velocity--
is a wind turbine appropriate?
The first question is,
well, what's the wind speed?
And then there's a
coefficient of performance,
which just is a reality that
wind turbines are not perfect.
And so there's a
hypothetical limit.
And if you google
the best limit,
you can find the proof that's
appealing-- it's kind of cool--
of almost 0.6 is your
hypothetical maximum
efficiency.
And then a typical limit in
reality is anywhere from 1/2
for a really sweet
horizontal-axis wind turbine
to less than 1/10 for a
vertical-axis wind turbine
that I'll show you later
that's really old school
but does the job
when you need it.
So the other equation that
you want to think about
is the capacity factor.
So I've seen some
websites that say, wind
is so much better than
solar because wind is 24/7.
Well, not really.
[LAUGHS] Like, unless
you're getting up way
into the atmosphere--
and even then,
there's a lot of variation--
wind is not 24/7.
There's a tremendous
amount of variation.
And so it's generally
20% to 40% of the time
is how often your
turbine is generating
power, which is starting
to sound more like solar,
actually.
So that's one thing to
definitely keep in mind.
OK, so a typical power curve--
so at some point,
at some given speed
is when the turbine
starts actually turning
because, up until then,
it can't physically
turn because the wind
forces aren't high enough.
And then your output in terms
of power is very, very low.
And then you have an
average wind speed
that's generally somewhere
around here, which
is giving you half of the
wind power or the power
that you'd like.
And then you have a
maximum wind speed,
and then you're
happy, happy, happy.
And then at some
point, it gets so high
that you have to shut
the turbine down,
or else you're in trouble.
So that's just a
good general way
to think about what's happening
over different speeds because--
I'll show you later, we're
going to look at data that
shows you the different speeds.
So these are maps from
NASA that show wind speed
across the entire globe.
And you can see if it's very
dark, it's very low wind speed.
And if it's very light,
it's higher wind speed.
So if we could just fill
this part of the ocean
with wind turbines, that
would be pretty sweet.
But you can actually
see in Nicaragua,
which is right over here, you're
getting pretty decent wind.
Compared to, say,
if we were working
in these parts of Africa or up
here in Russia or something,
we wouldn't be thinking
wind turbines at all.
And you can see how
much variation there
is between January and July.
And so, of course, there's
a lot of seasonal variation,
no matter what.
And you can see this blue
is 7 meters per second,
which is getting to be useful.
For a horizontal-axis
wind turbine,
you need 5 meters per second.
For vertical, you can
go a little bit lower,
but 5 is a good rule of thumb.
And again, why we're looking at
velocity over everything else
is because velocity is cubed
for your power equation.
So great, I've told
you wind speeds.
I've showed you a NASA
map of the entire Earth,
but that doesn't tell you
much for a given location.
So one way to get a really
rough estimate of wind speed
is this Beaufort scale, which
was developed in the 1800s.
And it correlates what
you can visually see
and what kind of damage
you're seeing to the speed.
Some of the caveats on this are
number one, it's pretty rough.
And especially if
you're talking to people
in a community saying,
tell me about wind speed,
and giving them examples,
it's hard to remember
exactly what the wind is like.
Like, can you tell me what
the Beaufort scale was today
walking here?
I can't.
[LAUGHS] I don't remember.
I don't really pay attention
to the wind that much.
If you're working
with farmers, they're
probably a little bit more aware
of it than you and I might be,
but still, it's challenging.
And the other thing is
that a lot of these metrics
are on the ground,
and we're probably
talking about significantly
higher than the ground,
depending on what kind of
turbine you're implementing.
And so again, that
only helps you.
So if you're finding
out that you're probably
at 4 miles an hour, which is
2 meters per second and really
low, but at the
very ground level,
and you're building a
turbine that's 30 feet up,
maybe you have a shot
of getting enough wind.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Just a quick question.
Is there a uniform
scale from what
the wind speed at
the ground level is
and how it changes vertically?
Or is that a regional
thing like you said?
AMY BANZAERT:
Well, so it's both.
So yes, there are
some scales that
can help you estimate, if
you know what the ground is,
what it is up above.
But it also is really
dependent on what's around.
And so I'm about to
show you a tool that
helps a little bit with that,
but it's still very imperfect.
Ideally, you'd
have an anemometer,
and you leave it
up for five years,
and you'd have it at 10
different heights, 10
different anemometers, 10
different heights, and that
would give you actual real
data that you'd be psyched for.
But that would be a
really ridiculously slow,
expensive project.
And so a lot of this
is just estimations
and doing your best guesses.
So this, I'm sorry
for the web link.
As you'll see, this
website is web--
it's not even web 1.0.
It's like web 0.5.
But it has awesome
data from NASA.
So you go to this website
with that awful link,
and then there's a
bunch of different ways
to get this data.
And this is actually both
useful for solar and wind.
So if you're worrying
about solar data too,
this is really useful.
So if you don't know your
latitude and longitude,
you can click, use
the map to click.
Every time you do this,
you have to log in,
but it's very easy to
join because you just
type your password twice instead
of once you become a member.
And then it's slow,
but it looks so clunky
that I was afraid you'd
be turned off by it.
And it has good enough
data that I wanted
to go through showing you it.
So you have this
map of the Earth.
You click in the
part of the Earth
that you care
about to center it.
You click to zoom.
We're in the wrong part of the
world, but we're getting there.
I'm going to zoom in again.
And you can see like this
is data for a region,
not for a small town.
So there's all sorts of limits
to this data, but it's useful.
And so now you can
finally get your data,
and now you can get
crazy information--
so parameters for solar
cooking, for solar panels,
cloud information, which
can be really useful,
temperature, which
can be really useful.
And now we're getting to wind.
So you can see the variety.
So you can get 50
meter and 10 meter,
but because this is all
satellite data or airport
data--
so 50 meters is pretty high for
anything we're talking about,
and then 10 meters for
terrain similar to the airport
because they're
measuring at the airport
because that's the place
where they have anemometers.
So all of this data,
again, you have
to take with a grain
of salt, but it's
good to-- if you use
that in conjunction
with your own visual
observations in talking
to people, it's better
than nothing, which
is the alternative for a
million-dollar 10-year study,
which isn't viable either.
So we're going to just
look at wind speed
at 50 meters for that area
of Nicaragua I just selected.
And you can see
a 10-year average
and a minimum and
maximum variation.
So it's pretty helpful just to
get you into the ballpark of,
do I have a shot of
thinking this might work?
And then some of the other
things that you can select for
are how high you are--
so, Jessica, this is getting to
what you were interested in--
like, an estimate of where you
are and what your ground cover
is, and then it extrapolates
what the wind will be.
So it's pretty
useful and powerful.
Is it 100% accurate,
given that it's doing
really broad-based readings?
Of course not, but it's a start.
So it's a nice
resource to know about.
So now I want to
spend a little time
to talk about examples of wind
power in developing countries.
So one is the
Humdinger Windbelt,
which is totally different
from what you're used to seeing
and was developed by a
student who actually took
one of the first D-Lab
classes back when
it was the Haiti class.
And we have a Windbelt here,
but I couldn't find it,
so maybe during break,
I'll be able to dig it up.
Or if not, maybe we
can bring it by Friday
and show it in lab on Friday.
So the way the Windbelt works
is that instead of a rotation,
it just uses the vibration of
the belt, very similar to--
I don't if you guys
can remember the name
of the bridge that collapsed.
AUDIENCE: Tacoma Narrow.
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah.
Does everyone know that
Tacoma Narrows Bridge?
Yeah, so, well, google it
because you can see videos,
and it's awesome if you haven't.
So, yeah, it is totally
scary, especially because--
I have a friend who did
some research into it.
And so this bridge was
a super long bridge,
and it just had natural
frequencies at the same rate
as the wind was often blowing.
And so the bridge would
just go up and down
and up and down crazily.
And eventually, one
day, it got so bad
that it completely broke apart.
And the crazy thing
is that people
used to hang out on the bridge
on the really windy days
because it was so fun.
It was like a roller coaster.
And so it's extra scary
thinking about that.
So anyway, but this
is the inspiration
for the Humdinger, which just
has a really tightly pulled
belt in the middle of a
support structure so that the--
and you put this wind, so the
wind is going perpendicular
to the board.
And so that hits the natural
frequencies of the belt
and causes it to vibrate.
And then you just have
some magnets next to a coil
on the corner that allow
you to generate electricity.
So for certain
applications, this
can be a really low-cost
way to provide electricity.
And this is a pretty
relatively fancy way
of building it, but you
can imagine, and they have,
building it out of
like a PVC pipe,
which you can get anywhere,
and building it really simply.
And because there's very
few moving parts and nothing
rotating, it's much
easier to build than even
a vertical-axis wind turbine.
And so it's a really
neat application.
And hypothetically, you
could imagine building it
into structures like railings
on buildings and stuff
in order to power
different things.
So this is one example.
And we do have at
least a couple D-Labs,
so we'll make sure to show you
them later today or tomorrow.
Another example is the
classic wind turbine
in developing countries was
designed by Hugh Piggott.
And these are pictures of work
being done at blueEnergy, which
is in Bluefields in Nicaragua,
and we worked with them
last year, and they
build all these turbines.
So you can see there's
the support wires
and that you can rotate the
turbine down so that you
can do maintenance on it,
which is a really nice feature.
So that's one
classic design that's
pretty common in
developing countries.
And then a lot of people have
heard of William Kamkwamba.
Oh, there's the Windbelt,
so let me go back to that.
So I'll pass this around,
and the belt is not
exactly taught at the moment.
But you can see just the belt,
the magnet on the belt that
goes against the
coil, and that's
really all there is to it, and
then a little bit of circuitry
in order to generate power,
which is a really simple way
to do things.
AUDIENCE: So what's the idea?
The wind blows through
the tape there?
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah.
And the tape vibrates just
its natural frequencies,
and the vibration allows
you to generate electricity.
It's movement is all you need.
Thanks.
[LAUGHS]
So William Kamkwamba
was this guy--
where did he live?
Did I write it down--
in Malawi, and he just got
really interested in how
he could get electricity at his
house, and went to the library,
and read a bunch of
books, and got inspired,
and built his own
wind turbine, which
doesn't look like your
traditional wind turbine.
There are a few
design improvements
that could be made, especially
with better resources.
But worked well enough
for him to power
a radial at his house
and charge cell phones,
which got people really excited
so that they would start
paying him, so he
could start building
more and more turbines.
So it's a really cool story,
and now he's at Dartmouth,
in school, which he'd never
could have done had he not
built this turbine.
So he's a cool guy.
We may be able to get him to
come down to talk to our class
this year.
We'll see.
I'm trying.
But his advisor at
Dartmouth is very reluctant
to let him travel.
[LAUGHS] I'm sorry?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah.
But because he
didn't grow up here,
he's getting very parented
at a different level
than you guys are by the
professor at Dartmouth.
So anyway, so just a cool
example of something very low
tech that worked
really well and made
a remarkable change for this
guy and also his village.
And then working
all the way down
to the really simplest wind
turbines, so this is a--
I don't if you say it
as "pah-neh-mo-nee"
or "pa-neh-mone,"
but one of those--
wind turbine, which is
incredibly old technology.
This is the 10,000-BC technology
that we're talking about,
and it's just sails that rotate.
The sails-- actually, each
one rotates 180 degrees, So.
They're always
moving in the wind.
And this is not a turbine.
This is a mill.
So the act of it spinning
pulls this rope pump.
Maybe if I turn off the
lights, it'll be easier to see.
So there's a rope pump,
here, and the way a rope pump
works is incredibly simple.
You just have a rope inside
a tube that goes down
into the water table so
that you're getting water
through holes in the tube.
And then you either
have knots in the rope
or, if you can find
them, rubber washers
every foot along the tube.
And this is obviously
not to scale in any way.
And so the water gets
trapped between the washers,
and you pull up
the water that way.
And so this is really simple.
Again, we're talking about
ridiculously low efficiencies.
But if you need
to irrigate, this
is a way to do it that just
uses the wind that works really
well.
And this was built
for $40, which
is ridiculously inexpensive
compared to even
like a Hugh Piggott
wind turbine, which
is in the thousands of dollars.
So there are opportunities for
a whole range of possibilities.
And then, yeah, there's just so
many different types out there.
So if you look into
it, wind is one
of the areas where
people get really excited
and like to build
their own stuff.
And so you can
see a huge variety
of designs in the world.
So that's wind in a
very fast nutshell.
Are there any
questions about that?
OK, so next is micro hydro.
And micro hydro is kind of
funny because it's harder
to find really good examples
of installations the developing
world because they tend to
be just built but not well
documented is what I'm finding.
So I'm going to
talk more about how
you would determine if a
micro hydro installation would
be appropriate.
And I don't have as many good
examples of installations
that are successful, but
they're certainly out there.
So hydropower is just using
the gravitational flow of water
to generate power,
considering both--
the two terms I'm going to
use are head and flow rate.
So head is the distance that the
water falls, and then flow rate
is how quickly the
water is moving.
And so hydropower can be at
2 megawatts and much beyond
and is a sizable impact on our
nation's electricity supply,
for example, all the way down to
a 200-watt turbine or smaller.
So I'm saying micro
hydro for this lecture.
Probably some of the
stuff I'm talking about
is actually pico
or mini ranging.
And everyone defines
these differently,
so if you look up
what pico hydro is,
you'll see 10
different definitions.
So it's not critical that
you're getting exactly,
and you can even
see between pico
and micro, there's something
according to this definition.
Yeah, and with water
power, it's the same
as wind in terms of there's
mills and there's turbines.
So you can think of the old
grist mills and other things
that you can see in parts
of New England still.
Again, they're low
velocity, high torque,
delivering mechanical
power directly,
as opposed to a turbine,
which is much higher
velocity, much lower
torque to allow
you to generate electricity.
So those are the two extremes.
Yeah.
In terms of hydropower,
there's two methods.
So one is called
run of the river,
and that means that you're just
taking a chunk of the river
and siphoning it
off into a tube that
goes directly into your turbine,
and the other option is a dam.
So the benefits of this are
that it's relatively simple.
You can build it
locally, compared
to a dam is much harder
to build generally.
It's comparatively much
lower environmental impact
than a dam.
They're relatively affordable.
But when you have a drought,
you don't have any storage
like you have with a dam,
so that's the drawback.
And the dam is the reverse,
that you can accumulate
your rainfall, which is great,
but it's relatively expensive,
And.
There's a greater
environmental impacts
on the negative
because damming up
water affects the
local environment,
from the fish to just what the
fields look like, et cetera, et
cetera.
I'm sure you've heard
of dams in China
are similar that have destroyed
entire communities for building
dams on a very,
very large scale.
Yeah, and there's
more maintenance
associated with the dam, too,
in terms of silt accumulation.
It's challenging.
So we're just going to talk
about the run of the river
model.
So the components that
you have is something
called a weir that diverts
a chunk of the water
into your tube.
You generally have
a settling basin
so that any debris
settles out because you
don't want it going
into your turbine
because you'll
destroy your turbine.
A forebay, which
is a small holding
tank-- so you're getting
reserve capacity that way,
but that's talking
about variation
on the order of seconds or
minutes, not days or months.
Penstock, which is a closed
pipe flowing downhill--
that feeds directly into your
turbine that then generates
your electricity,
and then the water
is returned back to the river.
There's a lot of
different turbine types.
So one of the most efficient,
if not the most efficient,
is called a Pelton wheel.
And you can see it's got a
relatively complex geometry,
and so relatively expensive
and challenging to build.
But if you do, it's
very efficient.
It works well for a
high-head, low-flow situation.
So again, head is how far
the water is dropping.
Francis wheels,
which work better
for lower head, higher flow,
which has a spiral casing where
the water comes in and
spins this turbine and then
comes out.
Cross-flow, where the water
flows over this cylinder,
which has a bunch
of blades on it,
and that's what spins the
shaft to generate electricity.
A propeller, which literally
uses a ship's propeller,
and instead of the ship's
propeller being powered
in order to move the
boat, it's just using it
in the exact opposite way.
And you can see that you need
different types of turbines
for different flow
and head situations.
And then one example
is just literally
putting something in the river,
skipping all that extra stuff
of siphoning off the
water and just putting
something on top
of the water, which
seems really simple and great
until you think about all
the challenges in
terms of flooding,
and debris in the water,
and et cetera, et cetera.
This is a device that is
really prone to failure,
but it works in areas where
that's your only option,
or it can work.
Yeah.
So some of the considerations
you need for micro hydro--
one is that the minimum head and
flow you need is 3 feet of head
and 20 gallons per
minute of flow.
So that would be the
minimum head you need.
And if you have more
head, either, bonus,
you get more power,
or you can therefore
have reduced flow because the
power equation here is, again,
a coefficient of
efficiency times
the water density
and gravity times
the height, which is your head,
and Q, which is your flow rate.
So you can see that hQ,
you can keep constant.
If you increase your head,
you can lower your velocity,
and keep your power constant.
One nice just rule of thumb
is if you stick with SI units,
rho g is about 10.
So you can just plug that
in rather than having
to remember the density
of water and gravity,
though in SI units,
that's relatively easy,
but 10 is a nice way
to just remember it.
And then efficiency is somewhere
generally between 40% and 70%.
One other thing to
think about is just,
when you have your penstock--
so that's the water
going through the pipe
to get from the top of the
river down to your generator--
if your pipe diameter
is too small,
you're going to have frictional
losses in the pipe that
dominate and slow
your water down
so much that it's problematic.
So that's another
thing to remember
because it's tempting to
use small-diameter pipe
for a variety of reasons,
but that's dangerous.
So how do you figure out if a
river is appropriate for using
micro hydro?
So the two things you need to
know, again, are flow and head.
So the simplest method I
can find for measuring flow
is called a float method.
And you can imagine actually
doing this in a river
would be challenging,
so it's not trivial,
but it is possible.
So you mark about 100
feet along a length
that's ideally straight with
uniform width and depth, which
is comical to find
in a river, right?
Like, I've never
found a river that
has 100 feet of uniform
width and depth,
but you do your best.
And then you calculate your
cross-sectional area A. People
usually model it as a
semicircle, or a trapezoid,
or even just a
rectangle, calculate
that cross-sectional area.
You place a marker at the
start and end of your 100 feet,
and then you put
floats in the river
at the center of the stream
and time them to find out
how long it takes for them to
get from one end to the other.
If you want to get
complicated, you
can put them all along a
bunch of different points
at different levels to
worry about friction losses,
but you don't actually have
to do that to get a ballpark
measurement.
You can just do
it in the center.
And so good floats
could be a tennis ball,
could be an apple, or
something like that, whatever
you can find that floats.
And then you do have to
use a conversion factor
because your water is flowing
faster at the top of the water
than in the--
river than in the center
because of the friction
associated with the
base of the river.
And so you can use a
coefficient just to correct,
and then you get your flow rate.
Yay.
So that was a lot
of work, and all
you have is a flow rate for
one day, and water varies.
Like, flow rate varies
tremendously during the season.
So again, you can do
your 10-year study,
or you can just get some
data on annual precipitation
and when is the rainy
season, the dry season,
and do your best to estimate.
But, yeah, so that's how
you'd get your flow rate.
And then, in terms of head, the
simplest method that, again,
that I found that's
used is take a yardstick
or a stick of known length.
It doesn't need
to be a yardstick.
And you put on it
just a tube that's
clear that has the ends capped
that's half full of water.
And that's a really
cheap level, basically.
Or you can get a real level
if you have a real level.
But if you don't
have a real level,
you can just use a cheap level.
And then, hopefully,
with two people,
you put the stick at
the bottom or the top
and then just keep moving
it over and over again
until you measure your
head, which is a pain,
but people do it, and it works.
And actual surveying
equipment is really expensive,
and so you're unlikely to
have that in the field.
So if your partner
asked about this,
you have a method to
measure that's plausible.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Sorry, I thought the
head was the [INAUDIBLE] water.
AMY BANZAERT: Right.
AUDIENCE: So you're putting
this in the river perpendicular
to [INAUDIBLE]--
AMY BANZAERT: No, so for
the flow measurement,
you're putting your
floats in the water
and watching how long it
takes to get from one end
to the other, and that'll
give you a measure of flow.
And then your river ideally is--
let me get a picture instead of
trying to draw a bad picture.
So your river is hypothetically
going down the mountain
here and sort of doing a curve.
And so you're
saying, OK, well, I'm
going to put my weir
and everything up here,
and I'm going to put
my location where
I'm going to actually
generate the power down here.
So I need to calculate the
height from right here to right
here to get my head height.
So now I need to very painfully
go up the mountain in order
to figure out exactly how
high this distance is.
Is that cleared up?
OK.
OK, so that wraps
up micro hydro.
Are there any
questions in addition?
OK, so trips.
I want to start
talking about the trips
and spend actually the rest
of the time talking about it.
So, yeah, so let's do that.
So one change is that
one group of students
is going to go to El Salvador
now instead of Nicaragua.
And the reason for
that is Amy Smith
just came back from a
trip to El Salvador, where
she found a community partner
that's really interested in us,
and we think they're
doing great work
and are a solid connection.
And so we decided to see
if we could add El Salvador
and were able to in
about two hours, which
is remarkably fast
compared to the months
it takes to develop relations
with other community partners.
So hopefully,
that's a good sign.
And they're really interested
in charcoal, which is something
you'll be trained in next week.
So it just seemed
like a good fit.
So you've already
know about this group,
so I'll talk to you offline
if you want about it.
But, yeah, so we're excited
to be working with them.
So one group of
students is going
to be going to El Salvador,
and then two teams
will be going to Nicaragua.
And El Salvador doesn't
border Nicaragua,
but it's pretty close.
So we're not that
spread out yet.
We're not approaching D-Lab
development quite yet.
So the teams are as follows.
So AsoFénix will be going to--
well, Bus, Rosser, and Brianna
will be going to AsoFénix,
and, Carter, you'll be working
with them for the start
of the term.
I don't if I've mentioned this--
the teams that you go with
and the projects you work
on for the spring break
trip may or may not be what you
end up working on afterwards.
So what happens is the
week after you get back
from spring break,
we figure out what
projects are going to happen.
You tell me what you
prefer to work on,
and some students are really
psyched to stay on the project
that you went on spring break.
And, naturally, I'm going
to try to make it possible
for you to stay on the project
you're really psyched about,
and especially if you're
knowledgeable about it
because you just went
on spring break trip.
Great.
But if, for whatever reason,
you're like, you know what?
I can't stand AsoFénix.
I don't want to work with
them or any of their projects
ever again.
I'm not going to force you.
I'm hopefully not going to have
to force you to stay on that.
So there may be a
little shuffling.
So especially the people
who aren't traveling,
there's variation.
And I'm pretty sure Eric
has dropped the class,
but if he hasn't, he
would be on this group.
So the projects that you're
going to be working on--
one is, last year, the students
worked on the OJ bag sealer.
And so one thing is
delivering that bag sealer,
which ideally means reading
the final report from last year
and learning how it works so you
can show it to AsoFénix staff
when you get there.
And that's sort of like
the side-servicey project
as opposed to the investigative
parts of the work.
And then the 1, 2,
and 3 are the projects
that you're going
to be investigating.
So 1 is the
biodigester, which is--
they have biodigesters,
and they want
to be able to mix internally
so that the slew provides
better digestion.
And they're looking at
either hand or bicycle power,
and they have both concrete
and plastic biodigesters.
The second is a feed chopper
mechanism using bicycle power,
and I can show you video
of the feed chopper.
And third is a washing machine.
D-Lab actually has done a lot
of work on washing machines.
And so this is
one area where you
can learn about the existing
washing machines' designs
and then potentially bring
them down and even build one
while you're there
is a possibility.
And at the end of
going through all this,
I'm going to talk
about what you need
to do with this information
in the next few weeks.
And then you'll have time
to work with your teams,
talk to me a little
bit, your mentor if--
we'll show up at
2:00 to work with you
a little bit on all of this.
The second group of Juan,
Jessica, Elizabeth, Vivian,
Sid, and Curt is
going to Grupo Fenix.
Amelia Servi is
your trip leader.
She took this class last year
and did a summer fellowship
at Grupo Fenix, and so she
knows them pretty well,
and she's a grad student now.
And so the projects
are number 1,
they're really interested
in charcoal, both the stove
in a stove project that
was worked on last year
and making charcoal
generally, so
working with them on charcoal.
2, solar cell phone chargers to
develop more affordable version
for production.
They currently are working
on developing a cell phone
charger.
I can show you the
battery charger they have,
and it's pretty rudimentary.
And partly, that's a function of
their poverty and availability
of materials, but there is
opportunity to improve it.
And they would like to have a
really good solar cell phone
charger.
And then 3, they have a solar
cooker that's really expensive.
I'll talk about
it next week some.
And there's a lot of
opportunity for improvement
there to make it more
affordable to produce
and more aesthetically pleasing
and more functional too.
We have some data on there.
And then the third group in El
Salvador is called ASAPROSAR.
And so [INAUDIBLE],, Missy, and
Yuliya will be going there.
And, Adrian and Benji,
you'll be on that team too.
And so the projects--
so they're interested in a
charcoal training, and that
again--
so that would be
the service part.
Better ventilation
for smoke in the home
is one area of
interest, we believe.
Secondly is we think
charcoal stoves will
be relevant in El Salvador based
on what I remember of my trip
there.
I'm pretty sure they
cook with adobe stoves
just like they do in Nicaragua.
So it'll be relevant to work
on the stove project there,
and then potentially better
lighting opportunities too.
And a lot of these have a bit
of an architectural bent, which
we haven't focused on
much in this class,
but Yuliya is grad
student in architecture,
so she's going to help
with that aspect of things.
[LAUGHS] Guess what?
[LAUGHS] So, yeah, so we're
excited about that project.
And thanks for
the people who are
rolling with just being sent
to a new country with very
little notice.
So what do you have
to do with all this?
So right now-- and
by "right now,"
I mean in the next two hours--
talk to me and do some
brainstorming of ideas.
And your deliverable
for this step
is two annotated pictures
from each team member.
And so there's a lot
of different deadlines
for all these different things.
I'm just trying to help you
get through the next couple
of weeks in a way that you
actually get output and don't
save it all to the
last night, which
will lead to really
weak both packing
and help for your
community partner.
So this is all
hopefully in preparation
so that you can maximize
the value to you
and your community partner
for the spring break trip.
And for people who
aren't traveling,
you're helping make sure
they're maximizing their work,
and it's also getting you
prepared for doing the project
work after the spring break.
So I don't think this is
busy work for you in any way.
So that's one, is doing
a brainstorming effort,
and I'm going to
talk a little bit
about brainstorming
in a minute so you
have some guidelines there.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: By
pictures, do you mean
find examples of existing
technology or do sketches?
AMY BANZAERT: No, just sketches.
So yeah, so basically, I'll
show you this in a minute.
But when you do a brainstorm--
like, if I was
brainstorming wind turbines,
I might do a picture
that looks like that.
It takes me 10 seconds
to draw it, tops.
And that would be
really appropriate
in our brainstorming session.
For the pictures
you turn in, I would
want it to be a
little more refined
so that everything is drawn
a little bit more carefully.
There's a few more
elements that actually make
this a real device rather
than just something
disembodied an air,
whatever's appropriate.
Not many, if any
of you, are artists
or technical graphic designers.
And so I'm not looking
for an amazing sketch
that was done by a graphic
designer or artist.
I'm not one either.
But if you just draw
relatively slowly and carefully
and maybe do a
couple of tries, you
should be able to get a drawing
that looks decent enough
that it's understandable, which
is all I'm really looking for.
So then the second thing
is a literature research
on the topic, which you
may have time for as well.
But I want you to do a
brainstorm initially just
to get creative before you know
what's out there, necessarily.
So that's why we're doing
one, brainstorming, first.
But then a second set,
which you may have time
to do some today if you brought
laptops or what have you
is to get some
information on what's
out there so that you're
more informed about whatever
you need to be, whatever
your project is.
And so what I think would
be a good deliverable
for this is an
annotated bibliography,
and there's
guidelines right there
on how to write an
annotated bibliography.
The guidelines for
annotated biographies
are generally on the
liberal arts side of things.
And so they talk
about summarizing
what was the content, reflecting
on whether it was useful,
and assessing the
quality of the source.
And all those things
are good things,
but basically I
want you to focus
on summarizing what was
there and reflecting
on how it's relevant to your
project for each annotation
and assessing the
quality of the source.
If it's a crappy source,
just don't include it
in the bibliography, and if
it's a great source, include it.
And if there is something to
assess that you want to note,
don't hesitate to.
But otherwise, you
don't really have
to spend time assessing the
source in a written form.
So third is developing
project specifications,
and 2.009 does a really
nice job of defining what
a project specification is.
So I provided links to
their lecture and examples.
And so you're going to
provide project specifications
for each project using
the 2.009 format.
So that would mean an attribute,
a metric, a unit, and a value,
and you'll see the
definitions there.
The value is an actual number.
Like, it needs a 3 or a 7.
And a lot of those
numbers, you probably
won't be able to fill in
until after your trip,
and that's fine.
But what I would like to do
is come up with a best guess,
even if it's a range of a
couple of orders of magnitude.
Come up with a best
guess so that when
you talk to your community
partner, who often don't have
a lot of comfort with numbers
and may give you really
wacky numbers, if they're
giving you numbers
that are completely different
from what you're expecting,
that's a really good
indicator to you
that you need to keep
asking questions.
So that either you learn that
your assumptions are totally
off, which is a really
important thing to learn,
or that your community partner
isn't really understanding
the question or doesn't have
the educational background
to be able to give
you a useful number,
and you have to work in
a few different guises
to actually get to that number.
And we'll talk about
that on the trip prep
week of how you actually
do that process of getting
that information.
And then the next aspects are
doing a second brainstorm.
And it's up to you
as a team if you
want to do this in two stages.
So sometimes people like
to brainstorm on their own
for a bit and then come
together and bring those ideas
to a brainstorm and also build
on more in a group brainstorm
session.
Some people prefer just to do
a group brainstorming session.
So it's up to you.
But the second brainstorm
should at least
have a group component.
And for those, it's just
two annotated pictures
for each project.
And so it's fewer
pictures because it's not
per team member.
And so you guys
can just figure out
how you want to split those up.
Another thing is the
big questions you have
that you want to make sure you
get answered so that you have
those in mind so that you
make sure that by the end
of the trip you've gotten
answers to those questions.
And all of these questions
are related to figuring out,
can you actually
work on this project?
Is this a good project?
And if you are going
to work on it, what
is the appropriate deliverable?
That's the type of questions.
A materials list for the
trip-- so you may well
need some materials.
If you're going to do a
charcoal demonstration,
if you're going to try to
build a washing machine,
if you have a great
idea for a project,
and you want to try to actually
implement either a prototype
or something in the field,
your community partner
needs to know so that they
can provide the materials,
and/or we need to get them here
so that we can bring them down.
And so I put that
you don't need this
until the 16th, which is
right before the trip,
and that's only if--
like, that's the last desperate
time if you can define them
sooner, that's better, so that
your community partner has time
to get them, and/or we have time
to get them if you need help.
Oh, no, that was questions.
Materials is earlier.
OK, good.
That makes more sense.
And then, finally,
on the 16th, you're
going to do about a 15-minute
presentation on literature
search findings, your
project specifications,
the annotated pictures,
the key questions,
and your key expected activities
just so that you're well
prepared for the trip.
So that's basically
the assignments
apart from a little bit of
reading for the next few weeks,
which, again,
violates the syllabus
but hopefully will work
out or be OK with guys.
But I don't want to add
problem sets on top of this
because this is a lot of work.
Are there any questions
about all of this?
I have it printed
out so that when
you're working on it today,
you have something to refer to.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Did you get the
dates for the places you had?
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah.
So most people are flying on--
so people going to Nicaragua
are flying on Sunday
and getting back on
the following Sunday.
What about El Salvador?
So Juan and Jessica have
personal commitments,
so they're flying
back on Friday.
And do you know what El
Salvador is doing yet, Amit?
AMIT GANDHI: I think it's
Saturday [INAUDIBLE]..
AMY BANZAERT: OK.
So El Salvador maybe
traveling a day earlier.
So--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
whatever the days are.
AMY BANZAERT: I think so.
Yeah, the 18th is the Friday,
so the Sunday would be the 20th.
And we'll send out your
actual itinerary soon.
Some of the tickets are booked.
Others are just reserved, and
we'll be booking them today.
So there's a couple
of reading assignments
that'll be up on
Stellar shortly.
This is just a somewhat
different perspective
from the Paul Polak
reading you did.
And then this is directions
on charcoal making.
So both are quite short.
So I know it might be
seeming like a lot,
but these are very
manageable to get done.
So now I just want to go
over how to do brainstorming,
and then we can take
a break, and then
you can get into
your project groups
and do brainstorming and
start talking about the trip.
And then at 2:00, your
mentors will show up,
unless your mentor is Amit.
He's already here--
your trip leader,
and so you can get
support from them as well
and get to know them.
So effective and
fun brainstorming,
you require a clear
problem statement.
So for this case, it's
whatever the project idea
is for your community
partner project.
After you get back
from spring break,
you have about four
weeks of building,
and you have about
a $500 budget.
So while you'll see
I'm going to encourage
you to have really wild
ideas, and so if you come up
with a idea that completely
violates the four
weeks of building
in the $500 budget,
still throw it out there.
It's nice to have in your mind
a general sense of these sorts
of things so that you're not
only brainstorming things that
are in the 7-megawatt
wind turbine category
if you're thinking
about wind power.
So for fun and
effective brainstorming,
you're trying to
generate as many ideas
as you can in 15 minutes.
So 15 minutes is a
good length of time.
Sometimes you need a
little more, a little less,
but around that time for any
particular project statement.
And then you can, say, take
a break, take a stretch,
and then come back and work
on the next problem statement.
You want your sketch to really
be a picture with a few words.
So a lot of people, if they're
brainstorming weapons of war,
and you have your
8-and-1/2 piece of paper,
might draw this.
And I would say that this
picture is a lot more evocative
of what your idea is than
using the words big and just
a tiny drawing.
And those of us who are
not so good at drawing--
and I'm one of them--
are tempted to draw a really
small because you don't
want to show in
really big format
just how bad your drawing is.
But even being a
weak drawer, you
can still get your idea
across pretty well.
This is, like, a 3-minute
sketch for an artist.
So none of your brainstorm ideas
are going to look this crafted.
This might be the
actual annotated sketch
that you turn in that you
actually refine and spend
some time on.
So the 10-second version
is going to be a guy,
and you have a guy, and
he's shooting stuff.
And here's the person who's
unhappy getting shot at.
And then here's the wheel
that's moving your wall of doom,
right?
So this is a really fast
version of that sketch,
and so that's what I'm
looking for, not that.
But I just wanted to emphasize
most people start out
doing this, and you really want
to force yourself to do that
with maybe the description
at the top or the bottom,
but the picture should
dominate, not the words.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so I'm
still a little confused
as to how the three projects
that you listed on each slide
relate to the
brainstorming [INAUDIBLE]..
AMY BANZAERT: OK, yeah,
so the three projects-- so
if one of your projects was
the feed chopper, right now,
you know nothing about
that project, right?
So you may not be able
to brainstorm that
at all until you come
talk to me, which
is part of what you need
to do in the next hour
and a half is come
talk to me, so I
can give each team
a little bit more
detail about their
three projects.
But one of them
might be something
you can brainstorm on
initially if there's
a queue to wait for me.
But either way, once a little
bit about the feed chopper,
then that'll be one of your
brainstorming assignments
is the project, the
community partner,
needs this mechanization
of the feed chopper,
and let's brainstorm ways to
mechanize that feed chopper.
And just put out as many ideas
as you can in 15 minutes.
And a good goal is to be
generating at least three ideas
per minute, which doesn't
sound like that many,
but it's pretty challenging.
But that is something
to keep in your mind is,
I should be generating
three ideas per minute.
And so if I'm not, I need
to get crazier, probably,
and less inhibited in order
to successfully do it.
And so once you draw
this beautiful picture
with your group, what you do is
everyone's hopefully drawing.
And you just say,
hey, guys, my idea
is an advancing wall of doom.
And then you grab
a piece of tape,
and we're going to use the
three fume hoods as our boards.
So each group will be
around a fume hood.
And so just tape your
idea up on the wall
and then get back on drawing.
And if-- Curt, you had said
this advancing wall of doom,
and I love that idea,
I can say, yeah,
it's going to be an
advancing wall of doom.
But instead of
being wheel-powered,
it's going to be on--
on a big wheel
powered, it's going
to be on a bunch
of little wheels.
And so in other circles, that
might be considered theft,
right?
And you'd be really mad at
me for stealing your idea.
But in brainstorming, that's
really encouraged is to, quote,
"steal" people's ideas.
So have no worry about that.
You guys can work out
your patent rights
if you become millionaires over
your advancing wall of doom
later.
So what are the
rules of the game?
So one is deferred judgment.
So when I propose that I want to
make a wind turbine that's just
going to float in the air
magically with helium balloons,
and you see a few
flaws in that idea,
you just have to bite
your tongue, right?
And the one way you can
manage that is by saying,
OK, I'm going to
build on your idea.
And instead of helium
balloons, we're
going to use a post that's
attached to the ground.
But deferred judgment, even of
your own ideas and of anyone
else's.
If you're showing your idea, no
saying, this is really stupid,
but here it is.
Just say what it is.
Hopefully, everyone is coming up
with some really terrible ideas
as well as really good ones.
And some of those
really terrible ones
have a kernel of
awesomeness in them,
and so that's why it's
worth it to get them out.
One at a time--
so if everyone is talking
at once, it's ineffective.
So post them up one
at a time, and you
shouldn't draw three ideas
on one piece of paper.
You should have each piece
of paper for each idea.
As I mentioned, so building an
ideas, so theft is encouraged.
Don't be afraid of that.
Try to stay focused,
which can be hard.
Spending 15 minutes
trying to generate
three ideas per minute--
that's a lot of ideas, but do
try to do that.
And then, as I
mentioned, be visual.
And encourage-- use wild ideas.
Don't be afraid to be like,
oh, yeah, wall of doom,
but it's going to be made
out of peanut butter.
Like, something that ridiculous
just pops in your head,
throw it out there because
it may inspire someone
to say, well, not peanut butter,
but what about peanut shells?
That would be a really
low-cost way to make it, right?
And all of a sudden that's
slightly useful idea
for this ridiculous
wall of doom.
Yeah, and then once
you're done, you
can sort the pile to divide--
to get them into themes.
So you can just figure
out what are your themes
or what are your combinations.
Figure out, do those
themes actually make sense?
And then I'll often refine
and combine the best.
So those two ideas
from each group
don't necessarily have to be
the ones you came up with,
but ones that you think
are some of the best
of what you came up with.
Do you guys have
questions on that?
I went over that kind of fast.
But, yeah, OK.
So then for the next
hour and a half,
you guys can take
your 10-minute break
and then come back and do the
brainstorming, meet with me.
And then please remember to
fill out your money cards
and include the hours per
week on them that you think
you're spending on the
class so that I just have
a sense of how that's going.
AUDIENCE: But it's
a big blue box
with a lid that you
can open, and it has
a table built in that sits on--
AUDIENCE: Wait,
so how big is it?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] you
have a budget [INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: Oh, they make
it a different size,
but it's basically like this.
[PAPER CRUMPLING]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: No, no.
AUDIENCE: No.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: No, I'm
making a better drawing.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: I'm doing the same
thing except a better drawing.
AUDIENCE: No, we like ugly.
AUDIENCE: Go post it.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: Wait.
This doesn't make sense.
So what's [INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: Fine.
AUDIENCE: Parabola,
and it's like a--
AUDIENCE: That's a [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: It looks
like a funnel.
AUDIENCE: I like it.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHS]
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Steal your idea.
AUDIENCE: I'm trying
to get a parabola.
AUDIENCE: Well, then, make it.
AUDIENCE: Wait, hold on.
Let me explain what it
is, though, [INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: Oh, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
[LAUGHTER]
I'm trying to make a parabola.
So it's a parabolic
solar cooker.
AUDIENCE: That is not a
parabola, let me just say.
AUDIENCE: That's why
I scratched it out
so I could draw a parabola with
just basically kind of stealing
the idea from me.
And I guess our sole source--
they use solar cookers, and
they're in the Himalayas,
and they're really--
they really mobile.
You can fold them up
and carry them around.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: So that was an idea.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] anything.
AUDIENCE: That's
a great drawing.
AUDIENCE: No, [INAUDIBLE].
[LAUGHS]
AUDIENCE: He's like,
fine, whatever.
AUDIENCE: It looks
like a funnel.
AUDIENCE: You can redraw
those over if you really want.
AUDIENCE: So
basically, [INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
just [INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: My plan is to
email out [INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: Combination box and--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: --parabolic solar
thing heating some kind
of heating element--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: --and all that stuff.
AUDIENCE: --is.
So would that be liquid, then?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, that's a liquid.
And, oh, oh Shoot, shoot.
Sorry, it'll have to cycle back.
Not good.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: OK.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, that's
just [INAUDIBLE]..
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
[LAUGHS]
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: Cool.